from a safety protocol perspective
people think about like physical damage
not emotional damage I know this sounds
ridiculous I know it sounds ridiculous
but it won't be it's already happening
there's an app called replica where
people have an intimate relationship
with an AI chatbot and they hurt
themselves I was thinking about this
yeah okay in dating
what if you because
you dream
like a chat bot to kind of mimic the way
that you talk to people and interact
with people go on yeah but then I'm like
okay but what if we could all make AI
versions of ourselves and have them date
yeah like thousands of thousands of
other AI people and have that as a way
to turn out potential potential
candidates like I feel like that's gonna
be what's what's the
yeah what's the what no but what's the
point of like meeting 20 people if
you're like oh but if we just had our AI
versions of ourselves in Iraq they'd be
like oh your your method of conflict is
not going to match or what if the AI
version of you like sleeps around with
all the other AIS and it becomes famous
for that and it starts its own only fans
and then it becomes and you're like what
did you do you come back home you'd
realize like I don't I didn't want to
created a monster create a monster I
mean do I get a cut exactly that's the
question I have to ask but I think it's
definitely like yeah the the human
technology interaction is really
interesting because I feel like I don't
love any of the machines that I have in
my life really if you haven't you
haven't I mean I don't love my phone I
touch it all the time and it's there and
it's like constantly it's a constant
presence but there's nothing in the meat
that feels like oh I love this object
like I kind of despise it